do you think of our universe as just one
giant computation
I I would even kind of say Quantum
Computing is overhyped in that there's a
few things Quantum Computing is going to
be good at one is breaking cryptosystems
but we know how to make new crypto
systems what it's really good at is
modeling other Quantum systems so for
studying
nanotechnology it's going to be powerful
but Quantum Computing is not going to
disrupt and change everything
but the reason I say that is this
interesting group of strange people who
helped invent Quantum Computing before
it was clear anything was there
one of the main reasons they did it
wasn't to make a computer that can break
a crypto system
it was you could turn this backwards you
could be surprised quantum mechanics can
compute
or you can go in the opposite opposite
direction and say if quantum mechanics
can compute
um that's a description of nature so
physics
is written in terms of partial
differential equations
that is an information technology
from uh two centuries ago
the the equations of physics are not
this would sound very strange to say but
the equations of physics Schrodinger's
equations and Maxwell's equations and
all of them are not fundamental they're
a representation of physics that was
accessible to us
in the era of having a pencil and a
piece of paper
they have a fundamental problem which is
if you make a DOT on a piece of paper in
traditional physics theory there's
infinite information in that dot a point
has infinite information
that can't be true because in
information is is a fundamental resource
that's connected to energy and in fact
it
um one of my favorite questions you can
ask a cosmologist to trip them up is ask
is information a conserved quantity in
the universe
with all the information created in the
Big Bang or can the universe create
information and I I've yet to meet a
cosmologist who doesn't stutter and
not clearly know how to handle that
existential question but sort of putting
that to a side
in physics theory the way it's taught
in information
comes late you know you're taught about
x a variable which can contain infinite
information but physically that's
unrealistic and so physics theories have
to find ways to cut that off
so instead
there are a number of people
Who start with
a theory of the universe should start
with information and computation as the
fundamental resources that explain
nature and then you build up from that
to something that looks like throwing
baseballs down a slope and so in that
sense
the work on physics and computation
has many applications that we've been
talking about but more deeply it's
really getting at new ways to think
about how the universe works and there
are a number of things that are hard to
do in traditional physics that make more
sense when you start with information
and computation as the root of physical
Theory so information and competition
being the the the real fundamental thing
in the universe right that information
is a resource you can't have you can't
have infinite information in finite
space
information propagates and interacts and
from there you erect the scaffolding of
physics now it happens
the words I just said look a lot like
Quantum field theories
but there's an interesting way where
instead of starting with different
differential equations to get to Quantum
field theories and Quantum field
theories you get to quantization
[Music]
um if you if if you start from
computation information you begin sort
of quantized and you build up from there
and so that's the sense in which uh
uh absolutely I think about the universe
as a computer the easy way to understand
that is
uh just almost anything is
computationally universal but the Deep
Way is it's a real fundamental way to
understand how the universe works